[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we had a lot of meetings yesterday
on Afghanistan on the economy which is
doing very well we have the strongest
economy by far in the world the tariffs
have costs nothing in my opinion or
certainly very little we have import
prices from and through July all the way
through July and they're down 1.8% so
that the import prices have actually
gone down China is eating the tariffs
because of monetary manipulation also
they're pouring a lot of money into
their country because they don't want to
lose jobs they're losing as you probably
know because you reported it but they
lost it over two million jobs in a short
period of time and they want to make a
deal we'll see what happens but they
definitely want to make a deal I'd like
to see Hong Kong worked out at a very
humanitarian fashion I hope President Xi
can do it he sure has the ability I can
tell you that from personal knowledge he
certainly has the ability to do it if he
wants to so I'd like to see that worked
out in the humanitarian fashion I think
it would be very good for the trade deal
that we're talking about and other than
that if you have any questions
well we're looking at Afghanistan we're
talking to Afghanistan or both the
government and also talking to the
Taliban having very good discussions
we'll see what happens we've really got
it down to probably 13,000 people and
we'll be bringing it down a little bit
more and then we'll decide whether or
not we'll be staying longer or not we're
having very good discussions with the
Taliban we're having very good
discussions with the Afghan government I
think just that we've been there for 19
years who are like a police force and
that's about it frankly I think it's
very important that we continue
intelligence there in all cases because
it is somewhat of a nest for hitting us
if you look at what happened with the
world trade it essentially came out of
Afghanistan most of the people I think
they may not have come from Afghanistan
originally but that's where they were
taught so there's a big argument to be
made and I buy that argument you know
it's very tough when somebody's as well
this is a big breeding ground and it is
a breeding ground and we have things
under control very well with the small
force we can probably make it a little
bit smaller and then we'll decide it'll
depend on the Taliban it'll depend on
the Afghan government but there is a
case to be made and the case also is
that we're going to be leaving very
significant intelligence behind for just
the reasons I stated I can't comment on
that can't do it Maggie
well I think President Xi obviously has
this in mind because he probably would
have acted faster so I think he has at
least something in mind having to do
with trade because it's something he
could do fairly easily it could be
unfortunately very ruthless so I do
think it plays on his mind and I do
think he he is thinking about what I've
had to say it would have an impact on
trade there's no question about it
[Music]
little outer Maggie
well Greenland I don't know it got
released somehow it's just something we
talked about Denmark essentially owns it
we're very good allies with Denmark we
protect Denmark like we protect large
portions of the world so the concept
came up and I said certainly I'd be
strategically it's interesting and we'd
be interested but we'll talk to them a
little bit it's not number one on the
burner I can tell you that well a lot of
things could be done essentially it's a
large real estate deal a lot of things
could be done it's hurting Denmark very
badly because they're losing almost 700
million dollars here carrying it so they
carry it at a great loss and
strategically for the United States it
would be nice and we're a big ally of
Denmark and we help Denmark and we
protect Denmark and we will in fact I'm
supposed to stop I'm thinking about
going there not necessarily definitely
going there but I may be going we're
going to Poland and then we may be going
to Denmark not for this reason at all
but we're looking at it it's not number
one on the burner
well I'm not trusting anybody look I'm
not trusting anybody
it's a horrible situation that's going
on in Afghanistan it has been for many
years Russia tried to do something and
at the time they did it they were the
Soviet Union and now they're Russia they
spent all their wealth on trying to do
something in that land have been many
many great nations in that land it's a
difficult territory there are a lot of
very good people there I will say but
there are also good fighters we have it
very much under control as far as what
we're doing but the rest is you know a
lot of bad things happen in Kabul a lot
of bad things are happening in
Afghanistan and some very positive
things but we would look we're there for
one reason we don't want that to be a
laboratory okay can't be a laboratory
for terror and we've stopped that and we
have a very very good view I mean some
things are going to be announced over
the next couple of weeks as to what
happened who's been taken out a lot of
people have been taken out that were
very bad both Isis and al-qaeda
[Music]
well I guess that means Lindsey's a very
tough man yesterday huh okay what else
[Music]
you tell them to go away
no that was reported and actually it's
the opposite Huawei Huawei is a company
we may not do business with it all and
it was sort of reported I think the
opposite today I was surprised that we
are open to doing business were actually
open not to doing business with them so
I don't know who gave the report now
they have little sections of Huawei like
furniture and other things that we could
do but when you cut out sections it gets
very complicated what's being sold
what's coming in so at this moment it
looks much more like we're not going to
do business I don't want to do business
at all because it is a national security
threat and I really believe that the
media is covered a little bit
differently than that
so we're looking really not to do
business with Huawei and we're actually
talking about not doing any business
because again the rest of it is not
national security but it's very
difficult to determine what's coming in
what's not coming in and still Huawei so
we'll be making a decision over that in
the not-too-distant future but it's a
little bit the opposite of what seemed
to be reported this morning I had a very
good meeting with Tim Cook I have a lot
of respect for Tim Cook and Tim was
talking to me about tariffs and you know
one of the things that he made a good
case is that Samsung is the number one
competitor and Samsung is not paying
terrorists because they're based in
South Korea and it's tough for Apple to
pay tariffs if they're competing with a
very good company that's not I said how
good a competitor we said they are a
very good competitor so Samsung is not
paying tariffs because they're based in
a different location mostly South Korea
but they're based in South Korea and I
thought he made a very compelling
argument so I'm thinking about it
well I hope not I love Larry Kudlow I
think he's done a fantastic job he has
been going through health problems as
you know but I watched him this morning
he was terrific
I think Larry's a fantastic guy but I
haven't heard that at all
I don't see a recession I mean the world
is in a recession right now and although
that's too big a statement but if you
look at China China's doing very very
poorly but they've had I just saw a
report they've had the worst year
they've had in 27 years because of what
I've done and they want to come to the
negotiating table you know they're
having companies loser I mean they're
leaving the companies are leaving and
they're laying off millions of people
because they don't want to pay 25
percent and that's why they want to come
to the table I don't think there's
another reason other than President Xi
I'm sure likes me very much but they're
losing millions and millions of jobs in
China and we're not paying for the
tariffs China is paying for the tariffs
for the 100 times and I understand
tariffs work very well other countries
it may be that if I do things with other
countries but in the case of China China
is eating the tariffs at least so far
yeah Phil honestly I'm prepared for
everything I don't think we're having a
recession we're doing tremendously well
our consumers are rich I gave a
tremendous tax cut and they loaded up
with money and they're buying I saw the
Walmart numbers they were through the
roof just two days ago that's better
than any poll that's better than any
economist and most economist actually
say Phil that we're not going to have a
recession most of us say we're not going
to have a recession but the rest of the
world is not doing well like we're doing
the rest of the world if you look at
Germany if you look at European Union
frankly look at the UK I mean look at a
lot of countries they're not doing well
China is doing poorly parts of Asia are
doing poorly we are doing better than
any country or even area anywhere in the
world we're doing great and our consumer
is really really strong and it looks
like they're going to be for a long time
also when you go in and analyze the
curve the curve always means that about
two years later maybe you'll go in right
so a long time two years but I don't
think so interest rates are low I think
I could be helped out by the Fed but the
Fed doesn't like helping me too much but
it you know frankly we have money that's
pouring into our country because they
want the security of the United States
we have billions and billions of dollars
daily that's pouring and we've never had
anything like this because they want to
come into the United States that's a
great thing that means we can loan that
money out mortgage rates are at an
all-time low borrowing costs are at an
all-time low it's probably a great time
I told secretary minuchin that this is a
great time to refinance our bonds or
some of our bonds you know it's I mean
the money is pouring into the u.s. like
never before and like no other country
has ever experienced including China
money I mean China money everybody
they're all coming into the US so we've
never had anything like it I think our
economy is very very good
well I'd be prepared for we can do sure
we can do a lot of things but if it
slowed down it would be because I have
to take on China and some other
countries look you have other countries
that are just as bad as China the way
they treat us you take a look at what's
happening with the European Union they
have barriers they have tariffs take a
look at other I'm not going to mention
all the countries because you'll be
surprised but we're treated very badly a
lot of them by our allies which we did
very badly when all of that normalizes
we've got a rocket ship our country is
going to be stronger by far than ever
before I mean if I wanted to make a bad
deal and settle on China the market
would go up but it wouldn't be the right
thing to do I'm just not ready to make a
deal yet China would like to make a deal
I'm not ready
no no update other than Iran would like
to talk also I have to say also China
wants to talk but Iran would like to
talk they just don't know quite how to
get there look they're very proud people
but their economy is crashing it's
crashing inflation is through the roof
they're doing really badly they're not
selling oil even I mean we put the
sanctions on the oil is selling much
less I mean much less than we thought
it's it's like a trickle and they very
much want to make a deal they just don't
know how to call because they're proud
people and I understand that but I have
a feeling that maybe things with Iran
could work out and maybe not if you
notice they haven't taken any of our
boats they haven't taken our ships
they've taken ships but they haven't
taken our ships and they better not but
I will say this I really think that Iran
wants to get there they have a great
potential I say this about North Korea
North Korea has tremendous potential
also Iran has tremendous potential and
we can do something very fast but they
don't quite know how to begin because
they're proud people they're very proud
people but their country is crashing
their economy is a disaster they've got
to do something so let's see what
happens
so Congress is working on that they have
bipartisan committees working on
background checks and various other
things that we'll see I don't want
people to forget that this is a mental
health problem I don't want him to
forget that because it is it's a mental
health problem and as I say and I said
the other night in New Hampshire we had
an incredible evening I said it's the
people that pull the trigger it's not
the gun that pulls the trigger so we
have a very very big mental health
problem and Congress is working on
various things that I'll be looking at
it we're very much involved we're very
much involved in looking at what they're
setting
well we're going to look at a whole list
of things and I'll make a determination
then but I will say Congress is now is
you know meeting in a bipartisan way
we'll see what happens a lot of things
are happening on the on the gun level a
lot of things are happening but you have
to remember also it's a big mental I was
talking about mental institutions they
closed so many like 92 percent of the
mental institutions around this country
over the years for budgetary reasons
these are people that have to be in
institutions for help I'm not talking
about as a form of a prison I'm saying
for help and I think it's something we
have to really look at the whole concept
of mental institutions I remember
growing up we had mental institutions
then they were closed in New York I'm
talking about they were many of them
were closed a lot of them were closed
and all of those people were put out on
the streets and I said even as a young
guy I said how does that work that's not
a good thing and it's not a good thing
so I think the concept of mental
institution has to be looked at
unrelated to that I believe that the
concept also of voter identification has
to be looked at because you can't have
great security for the voter people that
vote you can't have that national
security unless you're going to have
voter identification it's something
people have to look at very strongly
Jennifer
yeah I did we had a lot of meetings and
the golf was the least of and I played
two days the golf was the least of it I
don't care about look I like golf it's
fine it's so unimportant to me usually
I'll play with senators I'll play with
people where it can help golf is not
important from that standpoint other
than it's a little form of exercise and
that's not so bad yeah yeah yeah there
is I mean I've approved the deal the
deal is approved got to be approved by
the Senate but I've approved the deal
it's eight billion dollars it's a lot of
money it's a lot of jobs and we know
they're going to use these f-16s
responsibly but we approved the deal a
lot of money and it's a great aircraft
and we really believe or we perhaps
wouldn't have done it they're going to
use it very responsibly but it's
tremendous numbers of jobs it's eight
billion dollars no no just I said
unrelated I wanted to bring that out
while I'm here with you
I think voter ID laws of if you look
motor identification so when people show
up to vote because if you look dude
Ischl watch made a settlement with
California I guess or Los Angeles where
they found over a million names that was
very problematic a problem and you just
take a look at that settlement that's a
lot of names you had people that were
well over a hundred years old that we're
voting but we know they're not around
any longer so you have a lot of voter
fraud the way you stop it the easiest
way is voter identification we have to
go and think about that I hope
Republicans and Democrats can both sit
down and work something out on voter ID
while we let the Commission the
Commission was having a tremendous
problem legally getting papers from
various states like California they were
absolutely hard lining they didn't want
to give this commission it was just a
quick Commission headed up by vice
president pence to look at voter fraud
the problem the Commission had is we had
to have a vast amount of lawyers which I
didn't want to bother with because
California and other states were giving
up no information whatsoever and the
reason they weren't giving up
information is because they were guilty
they were guilty of it and they know
they're guilty of it many many people
voted that shouldn't have been voted
some people voted many times what I'm
saying is we need voter identification
we need voter ID
maybe maybe I don't think Denmark has
been absolutely set in stone yet going
there but if I did I'd certainly talk
about it but not not top on the list we
haven't gotten there yet first we have
to find out whether or not they have any
interests look they're losing almost 700
million dollars carrying that's a lot of
money for Denmark they're losing a
tremendous amount of money so we'll see
what happens
well fox has always given me I'll tell
you Fox is a lot different than it used
to be I can tell you that Juan Williams
then they have the wonderful woman that
gave hillary clinton the questions that
was a terrible thing and all of a sudden
she's working for fox what's she doing
working for fox fox has changed and my
worst polls have always been from fox
there's something going on at fox i'll
tell you right now and i'm not happy
with it
i don't know what's happening with fox
but when they have like a juan williams
it's never said a positive thing and yet
when i show up at the fox building he's
out the old sir could I have a picture
with you could I have a picture and he
was 100% nice I mean you've never asked
me for a picture no no they have to run
it the way they want to run it but Fox
is different there's no question about
it and I think they're making a big
mistake because Fox was treated very
badly by the Democrats very very badly
having to do with the debates and other
things and I think Fox is making a big
mistake because you know I'm the one
that calls the shots on that on the
really big debates
I guess we're probably planning on three
of them and I rely very I'm not happy
with Fox I'm certainly happy I think
Sean Hannity and Lou Dobbs and I think
Tucker Carlson and Laura and Jesse
Watters and Jeanine we have a lot of
great people even Greg Gutfeld he wasn't
good to me two years ago now he sees all
I've done he said would you rather have
a great president or a nice guy I don't
know I think I'm a nice guy but nobody's
done in two and a half years what I've
done and I say that a lot and very few
people can challenge it the first two
and a half years nobody's done what I've
done in terms of tax cuts regulation
cuts the military the vets the choice so
many different things nobody's done that
yeah
well I'm talking to my people but
ultimately we don't want to do business
with wrong way for national security
reasons we'll see what happens I'll make
it a decision tomorrow it could be
temporary could be and maybe not but
we're going to make a decision tomorrow
I don't believe it I don't believe it
every place I go we have lines outside
that we have even phony stuff with that
you guys were in New Hampshire Maggie
was there you started that room was
packed and they had thousand Maggie they
were it thousands of people outside and
then I see some phony websites some wise
guys put up that place was packed and
the New York Times actually saw that and
actually there was a massive lag behind
and even the seats behind the flag where
you had no view because those people
came down to be on the floor but the all
of the people any empty seat you had the
people come down to be in the floor
because there was so far away plus he
had a big flag look we had I think they
said 17,000 people outside that couldn't
get in
the fire marshals closed it at a certain
level the arena announced I don't know
the people at the arena that I broke
Elton John's record and then I have fake
news the fact is that people tend during
his speech that I make they love to come
down to the floor if they're sitting in
the high areas and they're not allowed
for fire reasons to have any more people
so that was an amazing evening and you
saw the enthusiasm but but we had a lot
of people sitting behind that massive
American flag that couldn't see so they
moved over and they moved down and they
came down to the floors to speech on it
but Maggie Haberman was very fair and
she was there and she saw the beginning
of that speech every seat was packed but
then they tend to come down they do it
all the time
oh I don't know I fell I fell what can I
tell you do I think I'm gonna win yes do
I think I have more enthusiasm now than
I had before this you know the 2016
election yes I think we I think you
people do too and some of you have
reported it I think there is more
enthusiasm for president Trump than
there was even for mr. Trump because
what I said that I was going to do I did
the tax cut the the regulation cuts the
biggest in history in two-and-a-half
years more than and that's one of the
reasons our jobs are so good because of
the regulation cuts I just don't want to
comment on that well I can speak to him
anytime but he understands how I feel
I just can't comment as to whether or
not I spoke to him but I will tell you
this we're having very very substantive
talks with China and with others but
with China
I can't believe it you know I tell you
I've never seen two million people when
you talk about drought sighs Maggie
those are serious grounds the Hong Kong
crowds I mean that when they said two
million people on the streets that
really looked like two million people on
this day
now I think it would be very hard to
deal if they do violence
I mean if it's another Tiananmen Square
its I think it's a very hard thing to do
if there's violence and you know that
I'm president but that's a little beyond
me because I think there'd be you know I
think there'd be tremendous political
sentiment not to do something so I hope
because I think we're going to end up
doing a very good deal and I think China
by the way needs to deal much more than
we do but I really do believe that if
this weren't part of the deal possibly
something would have happened already a
long time ago well I'll tell you what I
do support I support Liberty I support
democracy I understand what's going on
very well over there I'd love to see it
worked out in a humane fashion and I
think they have a great chance of doing
it look I put out and I told you that I
really believe I have a confidence in
thee in the talents of President Xi I
think if he met with the protesters
within a very short period of time they
would work something out that's good for
everybody I really believe that he's a
very talented man I mean aside from
everything he's a very talented man he's
very smart very talented and I know him
well probably as well as anybody and I
believe if he sat down with them now you
know he's not that's not his deal
sitting down with people you know he
doesn't do that but I think maybe the
world changes I really believe if
President Xi sat down with
representatives of the protesters and
they do have representatives pretty good
representatives pretty strong
representative I've been watching and
seeing them if he sat down I think it
worked something out and I think would
be good for everybody
but it does put pressure on the trade
deal if they do something negative it
puts pression out that deal I can sign
by myself it's structured so I don't
have to go to Congress but I respect
Congress I respect the views of Congress
and I respect most importantly the views
of the people of our country and I think
would be much harder for me to sign a
deal if he did something violent in Hong
Kong
[Music]
are you talking about the rescission
yeah I support many of those things
we'll negotiate it out but you know I've
cut back a lot on countries you know we
give billions of dollars to countries
that don't even like us and I've been
cutting that a lot
we give billions and billions of dollars
to countries that don't like us don't
like us even a little bit and I've been
cutting that and we just put a package
of about four billion additional dollars
in and in some cases you know in some
cases I could see it both ways in some
cases these are countries that we should
not be giving to I don't think so now I
don't think so and if I thought it would
I'd probably do it but you know I cut
back 1.3 billion dollars a year to
Pakistan and when I cut it back I have a
better relationship with as you know the
president came in and we have a great
relationship Prime Minister came in we
have a great relationship with Pakistan
now he we had a really good meeting so
what happened I cut back 1.3 billion
dollars we have a better relationship
now I also cut it back on the
Palestinians because they speak very
badly about our country so I cut it back
on the Palestinians we were paying five
hundred million dollars a year now we're
paying nothing but I think we're going
to get further because I could see
opening that up again I think we're
going to do much better the way I'm
doing it you know we're trying to
negotiate a peace deal everybody said
that's the deal that's totally
impossible they talked about a deal
between the Palestinians and the
Israelis as the toughest deal you could
possibly do no matter what deal you're
talking about and I stopped payment on
five hundred million dollars a year but
I think they're going to make a deal and
I think one of the reasons they'd want
to make a deal is because of that okay
I probably will wait but we may put set
put out pieces of it we have some very
talented people as you know our great
ambassador and others we have some very
talented people but that's probably the
toughest deal of all peace between the
Israelis and the Palestinians because
they've been decades of hate and it's
tough to make a deal when there's that
much hate but I think I've helped it
very much by saying look until there's a
deal we're not going to pay you anymore
and other people should have done that
long before me so these are things when
you talk about rescission that's not
part of rescission by the way but we
have a lot of things like that in the
rescission Phil
I think we have a great cabinet yeah
they'll always be people change because
you know after you're gonna be three
years now it's a long time they're under
a lot of pressure and but I think we
have a great cabinet I really do I think
our cabinet is is terrific some of them
will leave for a period of time they may
come back I mean the relationship I have
is very good with the cabinet and with
others but you know it's almost three
years now if you can believe it right
and at a certain point of time people do
tend to leave well I haven't said
whether or not I would but I would say
naft is one of the worst seals ever made
in the history of trade deals if you
look at NAFTA and you take a look at
what it's done to our country thousands
of factories flows millions of jobs it's
been a one-way street and the u.s. MCA
is a great deal the unions love it the
farmers love it everybody wants it but
it's up to Nancy Pelosi if she wants to
put it for a vote she's going to get
overwhelming bipartisan support and I
view that as a bipartisan deal I would
imagine she'd put it up there's an easy
thing to do it will be totally
bipartisan which is good for the
Democrats and the Republicans and
everybody wants it I mean the union's
like it the unions hated NAFTA but they
love the US MCA the farmers above all
love it especially the American farmers
our farmers love it more than the other
two sides they love it so a lot of good
things going but we have to see they
have to put it up for a vote you know
it's political season if you haven't
noticed so they have to put it up for a
vote
yeah at some point maybe if she wanted
to yeah I really haven't I've been I've
been talking to a lot of things now I'm
very happy with Mike Pence I think Mike
Pence has been an outstanding VP I think
that he spend incredible in terms of the
love that a lot of people especially if
you look at the evangelicals and so many
others they really have a great respect
for our vice-president and so do i and
so did I think most people know I would
I wouldn't be thinking about that a lot
of people a lot of people you know
amazingly they bring different names up
and they brought a lot of different
names up and that's and that's by the
way it's important I'll let you know but
that's by the way standard you know
that's standard everybody thought that
President Obama was going to change
Biden they all thought that in the you
know second term he was going to change
everybody thought it and he didn't do
that but now I'm very happy with Mike
Pence okay thank you all thank you -
which one
so Congress is looking at it very
strongly bipartisan I put in certain
parameters which you somewhat know about
I'm also very very concerned with the
Second Amendment more so than most
presidents would be people don't realize
we have very strong background checks
right now you go in to buy a gun you
have to sign up there are a lot of
background checks that have been
approved over the years so I'll have to
see what it is but Congress is meeting
bipartisan a lot of people want to see
something happen
but just remember this big mental
problem and we do have a lot of
background checks right now I'm not
saying anything I'm saying Congress is
going to be reporting back to me with
ideas and they'll come in from Democrats
and Republicans and I'll look at it very
strongly but just remember we already
have a lot of background checks okay
thank you say it I have well I spoke to
him a week ago
and look I've had a great relationship
with the NRA and I will always have a
great relationship I've been very good
for the NRA
if you just look I mean we have now two
Supreme Court justices great ones and
who would have thought that was going to
happen and you know long prior to three
years so we have to and equally
importantly we will have within another
90 days 179 federal judges and I say
thank you very much President Obama
because he was unable to get him filled
I don't know what happened to him but he
was unable so President Obama did not do
his job and I inherited 138 empty
positions and honestly from his
standpoint and the standpoint of where
he's coming from that shouldn't have
happened and we did do one other thing I
saw last night where some people were
talking about criminal justice reform
very liberal Democrats I'm the one that
got it done and I saw that and I said
you know isn't a shame you do something
and I've had very conservative people
wanting it and very little
people wanting it but if you take a look
at if you take a look at that reform
package without the Donald Trump it
doesn't happen and you know what I don't
need the credit I get enough credit but
they never even mentioned my name and
these were people that were begging me
to do it calling me begging me like
you've never seen and now that criminal
justice reform is done beautiful package
wonderful they don't even mention my
name so stupid so stupid thank you thank
you